So that last TikTok video I made about me going to Charleston
and just talking about masculinity
and how I felt like I.
There just wasn't a whole lot of masculine men around.
Um, it's,
you know, got thousands of comments now
and just so many people on there having discussions
and a lot of. It's really hateful.
And that's fine, whatever.
But
all these people that are hating on the idea of men being masculine,
they have a very warped idea of what masculinity really is here.
But masculinity is so much more then just being brawny
and having big muscles and being able to beat people up.
Like, that's.
That's not my definition of masculine.
Like, sure,
that can go with it, but my definition is a man that's a strong leader,
he's brave, he'll protect you,
he's competent, he's responsible for his family,
for the well being of his family,
for providing for his family,
and he loves unconditionally.
That's my definition of masculine.
And all the people that are hating on it
have very obviously been hurt by some men in their life,
and it's very heartbreaking.
Just please know that there are good men out there still,
and not every man is out to be controlling and dominating
and make you a doormat.
And all of these super negative things that people think that,
that's just not true. Yes,
there's some like that, but those are the crooked ones or the bad ones.
There's a Lot of good men out there that are gonna hold your heart
and protect you and love you and your family and your kids
if you have them and do what's right no matter what.